[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Hey, everyone.
We're here at the Google
Cloud Next Developer Zone.
This is full of cool little
showcases, hands-on labs,
tutorials, and of course, the
DevZone Stage, where people
are able to come here and
learn all about the cool things
but really get their hands on
them and play around with them.
Speaking of which, we're at the
BQML station with Felipe Hoffa,
who loves data and BigQuery.
So Felipe, tell me
a little bit more
about what we're
looking at here.
FELIPE HOFFA: Hi, Mark.
So what we have here is a
Stack Overflow Predictor.
How long will it take for
people to answer your question?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So what
does that mean, specifically?
So I can go into Stack
Overflow, I can ask a question,
but someone's not going
to respond immediately.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah.
So I don't know
if you ever asked
a question of Stack Overflow.
It takes some time.
And you never know
how long will it take.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Right.
FELIPE HOFFA: Well,
with this tool,
we can kind of predict
how long will it take,
looking at all the
past data that we
have from Stack Overflow.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Now,
how do you do that?
Because BigQuery, you can
do a bunch of data analysis.
But you can't build a machine
learning model in BigQuery,
right?
FELIPE HOFFA: Well, you can now.
So I love BigQuery.
I love the analytics.
Thanks to the
public data program,
we have a copy of Stack
Overflow, the dump that they
publish every quarter.
So we loaded that in
the query and then
you can start running your
own SQL queries over it.
Anyone can come and run
any queries they want.
They have a free
terabyte every month.
So the first step
with data analytics
is just to look at
all your questions,
look at all your
answers, and get
an average of how long did
it take for people to answer
questions on Stack Overflow.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So people can
come here to the Next showcase
floor, play around
with this interface
here, change and see
if they ask a question,
and then based on the
machine learning model,
they'll see about how long
they'd have to wait for someone
to go in and answer it.
FELIPE HOFFA: Exactly.
So how did we go
from the analytics
of just aggregate group
but to a prediction?
There is a lot of
spaces in between.
Like, for example, to get an
answer for the Google BigQuery
tag at 8:00 AM for a
medium question that
ends with a-- doesn't end with
a question mark, that starts
with a Y. For someone that
created an account in 2017,
we're predicting that
it will take 53 minutes.
Maybe they will
not get an answer,
but with an 85% probability
they will get one.
And there is a chance of
being downvoted of about 7%
for these statistics.
Now, how did we build this?
We created a linear
regression using
all of these features and the
data that we had available.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So with all
this different information,
you can know when you ask
a question approximately,
hopefully pretty
relatively, when
it's going to be answered,.
But you could also
maybe even predict
when's the best time
to ask a question.
FELIPE HOFFA: Exactly.
If you want to go
the opposite way.
So let's say it takes
53 minutes on a Tuesday.
On Sunday it takes more like
an hour to get an answer.
But there is a higher
chance of getting an answer.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So
lots of cool information
to play around with here.
But people can also come
here and actually learn
BQML hands-on, right?
FELIPE HOFFA: Exactly.
So the alternative for
people that are not here
to see how I made this, they can
go to my blog post on Medium.
Just search for Felipe Hoffa,
When Will Stack Overflow Reply.
And if you're here on Next,
we have code labs ready
for you to run that you
can also find online.
But there are so many
ways to learn and get
your hands into these tools.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Perfect.
So lots of cool stuff from BQML.
Come down to the floor,
get started, or check out
the resources online.
[MUSIC PLAYING]